for the last like week I've been trying
to find the original our Kelly video and
I can't find it it is child pornography
but that's what Christina's got your
house put on the list
he's on a person I would be shaking my
head wrapped in a blanket while they're
carting Christine off like I had no idea
the person mr. utterson this woman's a
monster you know you have a computer
filled with PO not child pornography
because I have a daughter
[Music]
wow that's creepy 27 and she was 15
yeah she interview they say she the
issues oh we don't talk about my age
it's a secret cuz I think she was like
13 she's 12 this song her first songs
called age ain't nothing but a number
that yeah yeah and she wrote that and
are you kidding me you the
second they started banging he was like
I got a song I just think this is crazy
it's probably already in his diary yeah
you need this it's just about her
wanting the older guy what's
with the songs about her trying to
seduce an older guy and telling him it's
okay to her didn't she die at 15 no
no he died of like she was dating Dane -
oh that's right okay send a plane Kurt
no I wasn't it wasn't she promoting like
village of the Queen of the Damned you
know what happened yeah yeah she was it
was like overseas Hawaii
maybe she's so hot yeah she was what
would she became a woman yeah everything
everything I was watching us there
showing her she's like a pretty young
girl but she looks kind of 15 if
Chappelle's Show is yeah 2003 we've been
laughing at mr. Nardelli for 16 years
welcome to 20 years of laughing well
they say that uh they were on the tour
bus
and hit like about you been on a tour
bus and stuff before already sent him a
pistol on the back door is like when he
hit bumps like doors fly around
sometimes and and like the back
door flew up and they said he was just
Aaliyah jeez like the background
singer girls were like and he was just
her and everyone's like come on
I'm married and then I got an old
immediate on the marriage certificate
that she was 18 she was not 18 she was
15 okay 15 but her uncle I'm trying to
figure out like where her parents were
in this whole thing because her uncle's
the one that brought her around our
Kelly in the first place they worked
together I didn't know that at all he
went for it all he had a background
singer named sparkle who did a song with
him like they did a duet song at one
point when he brought up but they also
he was a good you civ I know I know it's
like she looks like a sparkle by the way
he's an abusive and shitty to everybody
like it really treats them very bad
controlling his which so he's like
it so he's actually not only a monster
but he's an asshole on top of being a
mom and so on a monster and I mean a
monster in the sense that he would also
he was like controlling and bullying and
putting all these weird rules and
curfews on his background singer that
sparkle chick or whatever and then
pissing on her niece is the girl from
the video now didn't he and his bass
players daughter like he this guy's
having no scruples at all he would he
pissed on his bass players daughter I
mean I assume he pissed on I don't think
he had one piss girl who was he mark
does he mark his territory I think he
always pissed on them play well he
brought up yeah he brought up Priss
pretty quick guys guys I hate to say
this but we have to dismiss this in
court because he goes by wolf law it's a
mentality it's whoever has the highest
this is acidic as cute when
we just keep saying it like even though
it's a creepy thing it's like he was
pissing on them but also them
children's true here's was just foreplay
can you about say here's the I
don't think you the girl in the
video I think it's just a pisser I can't
even piss with a boner yeah but I think
yeah if they don't just throw it
everywhere dude can you imagine finding
that out it's like dad I gotta tell you
somebody goes what's up baby
yes yeah you know your cash cow the hand
that feeds you know uncle uncle Robbo
the lead singer of Queens Reich the lead
singer Queens right I believe the story
oinks I met the girl who was a whacker
his daughter yeah his daughter was uh
his guitar player sick and got
pregnant by my sure I got this right
Christy you're a rock and become
pregnant all right already she got
pregnant by him and then started on our
side so that's right so she started
a guitar player is this silent
lucidity yeah I know now you know other
ones do by walking past the classic rock
station for five years in Tucson and
just hear like it's 96.1 emotional
Queens right yeah ballad really his
daughter lead singer's daughter started
your guitar player okay and was
like really into maybe even married him
and he goes
while I'm touring he was touring solo or
maybe it's Queens right but he goes
alright I'll make him a guitar player in
Queens like so he becomes a guitar
player you get a guitar player now you
get a hired guitar tech so she starts
his guitar tech oh boy well he's
tuning her up with that joke but here's
the best part of it she got together
with the girl got pregnant by the guitar
tech or some whatever the merch guys in
it no no then the lead singer goes
alright well you're gonna be the father
of my grandkids so you're in the best so
these guys got to play there's layers on
either side of him are two guys that
they erupt his daughter it's so we just
the thought of playing with silent lucid
while you stare across the stage of the
guy that took your woman you're like
yeah really her dad singing you go yeah
and her dad's looking at them going like
I bet you guys have all my
daughter this song at some point they
were key weirdos
yeah actually it's about her I'll do
that so funny when there's just
death staring each other then he sees
him there's a smile there I didn't have
a lot of motivation to keep going as a
band by the way the by the way this song
might be about her just so funny what a
weird and then she's just in the
audience with a lighter up just going
it's about me and I 2/3 of that
and one of them I made from his
there is a petri dish in my puss up on
that stage
you know which one is the dad the thing
that made it and the things that ate it
she that's my pot that's my proud papa
and flanking him is the dick that I did
yes
hey pop this isn't the UH this is the
first time those guys built either side
the Queen's like family knows I get it
mom got a piece too all right guys let's
play the songs come on a million times
with this joke we get it my daughter's
fertile she likes guitar that's guys I'm
on the tour bus when the bathroom door
fell open and we're all banging our eyes
alright guys I get another one on old
Jeff okay okay but this State Fair isn't
gonna rock
no Liberty Ohio tonight has the better
part of 170 people out there god damn it
we're gonna play that in five other
songs and the two guys that thought it
was Queens of the Stone Age you leave
should we open with new stuff thank you
guys unplug from my daughter for a
second so art Kelly his bandmates
kids yeah this guy was just a
straight-up month
he's a component and he's a predator but
he's definitely a sickness but
didn't he also have like a walk-in
closet of like either kiddie porn or
porn than like most of it was completely
disgusting or remember they yeah they
wanted to I don't know if they want like
Al Capone's vault yeah if you wear
different like on cribs yes my kiddie
porn room oh this right here I mean
you're gonna love that's a sauna in the
bathroom now this closet that's where I
keep all my kids getting yeah
this fauces salad gold you ever seen a
eight-year-old get pissed off
oh I got some Thai stuff that is
definitely illegal because they don't
even allow it over there and they got no
rules
dude he hung out that high schools i am
stressed about the SATs is that
art killed yeah I mean he's just sitting
there guzzling a gallon of water soot
all these teenagers that he got pregnant
and all of them it was always a
situation like he was just like at the
mall and like they show him going them
all being like harbor at the mall see we
could lay low but he's going to the mall
to see if seven 16 year old girls in 17
old girls come up to him any and then he
goes and has it's the same move he has
people come back it's all these girls
that think they're gonna be like backup
singers or or have a chance of their
career and they go and there's so and
you see this what's leading up to I saw
a later episode I don't know what much
of the middle of it yeah but on a later
episode there's a family still looking
further
who's with him and and her old thing at
first was like getting very mad when her
parents like followed her to the hotel
one time when she was like 14 or 15 holy
they Faro and she came downstairs
yelling at them like this it's like he's
gonna make me famous like he's gonna
we've always talked about this like I'm
like he's gonna help my singing career
amantha so the more the parents start
going like maybe we are maybe this is
just business or whatever and A's got
her crazy what an absolute piece
of yeah just hanging out at the
mall though he's just dude trying to lay
low but he's like pretending to like try
on hats a Tosh he's gotta keep dodgin
kiosk people he just walked alright
kiosk hey you need a folder for your
phone he goes it's good I'm walking
through the mall you just hear him go
outside of forever21 yeah he walks by
Talbot's and gets nauseous that's all
he's hot he's hiding he's hiding inside
the shirt racks of justice hey what's up
they say low-rises back in he goes I I
just I was just looking to purchase an
American Girl for little girls that I
won't what's that there's a song
I'm cutting let's take our last break
here fine because I'll tell you what's
way to piss on the moment okay what we
looked at what was fun yesterday what
I'm bummed you missed an cuz you would
have really enjoyed is at one point a
later episode when are Kelly's ex-wife
was leaving him mm-hmm
she describes what she does was went on
the domestic abuse website yeah and
there's a bunch of questions they asked
you yeah she had seven oh I watch the
instant story she was 17 questions and
she goes and and he there was only three
things he had not done to me so we went
on at me and Christina Beck and fine
yeah we were both abused abused by each
other yeah you guys both abused each
other yeah we're dual abusive we're not
violent okay and we never like break up
a thousand times and
why are we stopping this train guys I'm
saying so it's fine
so what's the white or the practice
chucks I guess what I feel worthless
it's fine when we get her a spear yeah
once you have a spear Christina Ozzy
it's a fair fight it will be right back
with more bonfire and nunchucks and
pieces of come on breathing on the
phone miss little son please get off hey
is this the cops this is it or cami if
you are the cops I'm gonna go to the
mall get an Orange Julius and some yummy
buzz if you're for real meet me there I
don't know you till we get outside these
fields do you have a daughter game stop
checking off slap bracelets for my new
bitch is Claire's accessories it's
raining Percy I'm coming buckets at
Gymboree do you need another quarter for
that airplane
I love watching women write that zebra
slide in the middle of the mall oh hi
didn't see you come in there I'm Dan
Soder I'm big Jay oakerson we're from
the bonfire on Comedy Central radio
sirius XM 95 make sure you watch our
videos every thursday on comedy central
youtube fresh exclusive visual